[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад до нашого уроку англійської мови,
і я щасливий, що Пол сьогодні
тут зі мною, привіт, Пол, привіт, Боже, і
я дуже радий сказати, що 10-й рік
дізнається про роботу та кар'єру  дуже
важливо для вас, як правило, починає думати
про те, що вони хочуть робити в майбутньому
правильно, і сьогодні ми поговоримо
про приклади для наслідування для підлітків
Пол, чи був у вас зразок для наслідування, коли ви
були підлітком, ймовірно, спортивний і
чимало  справді спортивні герої, можливо,
кілька гравців у регбі, кілька футболістів, але
ніхто ніхто зараз не оглядаючись
ретроспективно ніхто, хто дійсно був
зразком для наслідування, що є спортом зараз,
моделі для наслідування мають бути важливішими, ніж
просто спортсмени чи музиканти, тому ви думаєте,
що взірці для наслідування це ті  люди,
які повинні бути героями для
підлітків, так, якщо ви, якщо у вас є зразок для
наслідування, просто вмієте робити щось, що
насправді не є зразком для наслідування, на мою думку, вони
повинні бути такими, як ви кажете, герой,
надихаючий і мати гарну мораль  я
бачу, добре, я покажу тобі кілька
фотографій, можливо, ти добре знаєш цих людей,
тож ти знаєш цю дівчину, на жаль, я
не помічаю іди, я бачив цю дівчину,
перш ніж вона прославилася модою, але я
не пам'ятаю  її звуть
так, її звуть таббі, і вона справді
відома у світі моди, що
ви думаєте про неї в підлітковому віці.
висловити свою індивідуальність
- це хороша риса мм-хм,
сьогодні ми послухаємо її,
і ми дізнаємося більше про Террі, добре,
а що ти думаєш про цього хлопця чи
цього хлопця, якого я знаю, я розумію, що цей хлопець дуже
відомий, це має бути  Джастін будь вульгарним
так, це Джастін Бібер, можливо, вам
не подобається його музика, хлопці, можливо, ви не любите
його пісні тощо, але ви
не можете не визнати його як підлітка, який досяг високих результатів, тому що
він почав свою
кар'єру, коли йому було 14
Чи можете ви уявити Павла, коли ви почали
свою кар'єру?  Ну, я навіть не знав, чим
я хотів би займатися чи бути, поки мені не виповнилося 28
29 з 14, але він почав свою кар'єру,
і він став дуже відомим і продуктивним,
коли йому було 14, дивовижно так, я знову ж
таки, хлопці, ви можете не любити  його музику,
ви можете не слухати її пісні, але
насправді він дуже успішний
підліток, раніше він був добре, тепер
давайте приготуємося до завдання на прослуховування, яке ми
маємо сьогодні, подивіться на цю
таблицю, і ви маєте  слова, і
ви повинні заповнити слова у
потрібну групу, тому ми підемо туди
слухачі фотографи редактори читачі
шукачі талантів шанувальники найкращі дизайнери та
послідовники Я думаю, що Павло,
будь ласка, поясните нам, що означає
розвідувач талантів, щоб розшукати таланти  може бути
в багатьох різних сферах роботи,
але розвідувач талантів, наприклад, молода
дівчина на ім’я Таві,
вона мене виправдала, якщо я помиляюся, її
помітив розвідник талантів, або, можливо, це
був Джастін Бібер, один із них, його
помітив  розвідувач талантів, щоб вони були
просто, можливо, ви робите щось звичайне
на вулицях або, можливо, ви дуже
приваблива молода дівчина, що йде
вулицею, і розвідник талантів з
модельного агентства бачить, що ви підходите до вас,
тому розвідники талантів, очевидно, талант
шукають талант, а розвідник означає
шукати та знаходити мм  -Хм, тому ті люди, які
шукають талановитих дітей чи не
тільки дітей, добре, і у нас є дві колонки,
тому в першому стовпці написано, що люди, які працюють
у сфері мистецтва та медіа, та аудиторія для
мистецтва та медіа, добре, хлопці, у вас є
хвилина або  менше, щоб поглянути на це
слово і заповнити дві колонки
словами, які, на вашу думку, мають бути там добре,
хлопці, то, будь ласка, поверніться до
цієї таблиці і давайте перевіримо відповіді,
щоб вони прийшли,
щоб люди, які працюють у мистецтві та медіа
фотографи редактори найкращі дизайнери та
шукачі талантів, а глядачі мистецтва
та медіа послідовники слухачі
читачі та шанувальники Сподіваюся, ви
правильно виконали це завдання добре, ми готові
до завдання прослуховування перш за все  давайте
подивимося на це завдання з кількома виборами,
воно виглядає справді гідним, тому є
багато слів, але завдання не таке
складне, давайте подивимося на
перше речення, щоб ми перейшли до нього, як багато
відомих невдалих підлітків, і
три варіанти використовують нові технології  працює
з раннього віку і надихався
відео YouTube
добре, хлопці, який, на вашу думку,
правильний варіант, ви послухаєте, і ви
побачите, але насправді не побачите, ви
послухаєте, і ви отримаєте відповідь добре,
другий варіант, початковий курс Джастіна Бібера
співати з зіркою R&B
або надсилати відео шукачам талантів чи
публікувати відео на YouTube, можливо, ви це знаєте
,
але чи не могли б ви послухати та слідкувати
за інформацією, яку ви отримали під час
прослуховування, номер три,
деякі люди кажуть, що Джастін Бібер є
найвпливовішою людиною  у світі,
тому що у нього було так багато пісень номер один
, у нього так багато підписників у
Twitter,
я його дружив із Бараком Обамою, тому
Пол, що ти вважаєш правильним
один він американець, тому він міг би дружити
про Барака Обаму, але, ймовірно, ні, я
думаю, що це, ймовірно, Twitter один,
можливо, добре номер чотири негативний
наслідок Слави Джастіна Бібера в тому, що
він дуже мало приватний, людям
нудно чути про нього або люди
критикують його  зовнішній вигляд Я часто чую, як
люди критикують Джастіна Бібера за його
зовнішність, але насправді це те, що
негативний наслідок: ні, він повинен
пишатися своєю індивідуальністю, як він
одягається. Я думав, що не буду нікого критикувати
за зовнішній вигляд, але, можливо,
ви знаєте, що у нас є фраза  у кожного
є термін придатності, і він відомий
досить довго, тому, можливо, людям
набридло чути про нього, можливо,
добре, тоді номер п’ять Таві Гевінсон
завела модний блог, коли їй було 11
років або коли вона навчалася в 11-му
класі  школі або в 2011 році вам доведеться
послухати день, щоб почати добре, а
тепер друга партія питань добре
питання номер шість
Ruki означає новачок a  фанат або хтось,
хто погано вміє щось добре це
новачок американець або британське слово
я чув це англійською я чув,
як англійці розмовляють найменше, але,
ймовірно, походження може бути американським, я
б не хотів сказати, якщо це  Американська або
англійська, але я знаю відповідь, добре, добре,
а потім приходить новачок Талі номеру 7, який
дозволяє читачам публікувати свої
фотографії або незабаром мав багато
читачів або був помічений Карлом Лагерфельдом,
добре зірковий новачок. Я вам підказую,
що це журнал  добре,
потім приходить номер вісім, коли деякі люди
не вірили, що у твій вік,
Таві спочатку була сумна і сердита, або вона
вирішила напасти на них у відповідь, або вона
повністю ігнорувала їх і продовжувала
працювати добре, Пол, як ти думаєш, якою була
її реакція, я не  зрозуміло, чому була реакція,
але я б рекомендував її
діяти, щоб ви повністю зрозуміли,
якщо хтось любить нападати на
вас або критикувати вас, найкращий варіант
- ігнорувати їх і просто продовжувати працювати,
показуючи їм, наскільки ви успішні  бути
завдяки своїй роботі, можливо, добре номер дев'ять
кмітливих співробітників, тільки підлітки є
письменниками і фотографами різного віку
або дуже невелика група людей,
це непроста причина, коли ви
підліток, і ви хотіли б
співпрацювати тільки зі своїми однолітками або
людьми  будь-якого віку, слухайте уважно
число-10 Луїза
, це людина, яка
опитується. Нам важко
вести нормальне життя,
коли ти письменник, то більше
тиск, коли ти виконавець, добре,
хлопці, я  Я б хотів, щоб ви витратили одну хвилину,
щоб переглянути першу групу
запитань, а ви, будь ласка,
погляньте на другу групу,
а потім, будь ласка, будьте готові до
завдання на аудіювання, ви побачите всі ці
запитання на екрані, а потім слухатимете
на  програма у нас є інтерв'ю
з кимось, хто писав книгу
про підлітків високих досягнень, вітаємо
Луїзу Харді привіт, як приємно бути тут
Луїза багато з цих підлітків, які
досягли  Успіх і слава на ранніх етапах
досягли цього завдяки використанню технологій, чи
не через ведення блогів чи використання YouTube
чи Twitter, і найкращим
прикладом цього є Джастін Бібер, оскільки я
думаю, що всі на планеті знають, що він
почав з публікації відео на YouTube за
адресою  у віці 14 років і був помічений
розвідником талантів, який працював із R&B
співаком Ашером,
після чого він дуже швидко став
світовою сенсацією, так, я чув, що
минулого року про нього говорили, що він був більш
впливовим, ніж Обама, так,
тому що він  номер один у Twitter, у
нього понад 35 мільйонів підписників,
кожні дві секунди з'являється новий. Компанія, яка
аналізує соціальні мережі під назвою хмара, сказала,
що він найвпливовіша людина
в світі через це, але чи
дійсно він має більший вплив на них, Обама,
хм.  але все це розкриття має
негативні наслідки для молодих людей
і у нього великі проблеми з конфіденційністю
, за ним скрізь стежать папараці,
і це погано для всіх,
не заважай підлітка добре, давайте звернемося
до зовсім іншого підлітка,
дикуна Евенсен була ще молодшою, коли вона
починала, чи не так, їй було всього 11
років  Старий, коли вона завела модний
блог під назвою style rookie, до речі, для
британських підлітків rookie — американське
слово, яке використовується для позначення людини, яка в чомусь новачок,
о, дякую, у своєму блозі вона
опублікувала фотографії себе в незвичайних
комбінаціях одягу та написала про
них так  деякі з них були досить дивними,
так, я вважаю, що багато високої моди
все одно дивно, вона швидко набрала
величезну кількість читачів до 300 000 читачів на
день, і багато з них були дорослими, серйозні
модні журнали брали у неї інтерв'ю та
посилали на покази мод в Європі  і
щоб познайомитися з такими провідними дизайнерами, як Карл
Лагерфельд, деякі люди не вірили, що
вона така молода, як і була, чи вони знали, що
один журнал надрукував статтю, в якій говорилося,
що письменниця не відома  Ієв Таві було всього
12, і це її засмутило, але вона повернулася
назад і продовжила вести блог, коли вона
стала старшою, Таві почала цікавитися
іншими речами, окрім моди, у 2011 році,
коли їй було 15, вона менше ніж за тиждень запустила
журнал для новачків та онлайн-журнал для
підлітків.  мав 1
мільйон читачів. Я бачив це дуже
вражаюче, чи не
всі дівчата-підлітки слухають, ви повинні
переглянути журнал для новачків так, я думаю, це
фантастично, і Леді Гага покликана бути
майбутнім журналістики, у неї працюють близько
50 письменників і фотографів, і дорослі
і підлітки на новачках, але вона
редактор із загальним контролем, і весь цей
час вона продовжувала вести нормальне
життя, чи не
так, вона живе дуже звичайним життям у
маленькому містечку і ходить до школи і так далі
їй немає навіть 20  але я думаю, що
написання та редагування дуже відрізняються
від виконавців, є
великий
тиск з боку шанувальників і преси,
хоча деякі актриси, як Емма Вотсон,
здавалося, керують особистим життям і  d
отримує звичайну освіту так Еммі
Уотсон зараз, звичайно, 20, але
добре, хлопці, це кінець
слухання, яке ви слухали інтерв'ю
вперше, у вас буде
друге прослуховування після того, як ви виконаєте перше
завдання, добре, давайте
подивимося  перша правильна відповідь полягає в тому, що багато
відомих і успішних підлітків
використовували нову технологію, Пол, ви
пам'ятаєте технологію, яку використовував Джастін Бібер,
він не використовував YouTube, так, він використовував
YouTube, і він опублікував свої відео, саме
так його помітив розвідник талантів
і тому що він публікував відео
на YouTube, і це правильна відповідь
на друге запитання, тепер третє
, і люди кажуть, що Джастін Бібер є
найвпливовішою людиною у світі,
тому що у нього так багато підписників у
Twitter щосекунди плюс два
, це добре, що  Тоді
негативний наслідок Слави для Джастіна
Бібера полягає в тому, що йому бракує конфіденційності, у
нього дуже мало конфіденційності.
Я за ним стежать папараці та
журналісти  і так далі, добре, а що щодо
Тобі,
вона завела свій блог, Пол, ти
пам'ятаєш, коли вона була в 11-му
класі середньої школи ні насправді, коли їй було
11 років, так, вона навіть не була
підлітком, ніж ще дитиною, так, і
наступний
«Рукі» означає «початківець», хто починає
щось, а потім створює стиль. У Рукі незабаром з’явилося
багато читачів, і Деббі
дала інтерв’ю Карлу Лагерфельду, тоді,
коли люди не
вірили в її розумність у підлітковому віці, вона спочатку була
дуже сумною та сердитою, але  потім вона
почала ігнорувати їх, але спочатку в
підлітковому віці вона була сумною і злий, а потім
номер дев'ятий Треві наймає письменників і
фотографів різного віку, що насправді
показує, що вона дуже зріла людина, що вона
відкрита до різних думок різних
вікових груп, тож і останнє запитання
Луї думає, що Таві
Луїс думає, що це важко, коли
є більший тиск, коли ти
виконавець, але не письменник чи
щось інше. Добре,
хлопці, ви збираєтеся слухати
співбесіду вдруге, і
наступне завдання – заповнити пропуски в цьому завданні,
вам доведеться послухати цифри або
дуже короткі слова, вони не дуже
складні, і насправді це завдання
досить легке, але вам потрібно буде
послухати  усе інтерв'ю ще раз, можливо,
ви запам'ятаєте деякі цифри, добре,
знайдіть час, у вас є хвилина,
перегляньте всі речення та будьте готові
до другого прослуховування
[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ви зараз переглянете цілу
купу речень  ви, будь ласка,
послухайте ще раз і заповніть прогалини далі
в програмі у нас є інтерв'ю з
кимось, хто писав книгу
про підлітків високих досягнень, вітаємо
Луїзу Харді привіт, як приємно бути тут
Луїза, багато з цих підлітків, які
рано досягли успіху та слави  вони
зробили це завдяки використанню технологій, чи
не через ведення блогів чи використання YouTube
чи Twitter,
і найкращим прикладом
цього є Джастін Бібер, оскільки я думаю, що
всі на планеті знають, що він почав
пішов, опублікувавши відео на YouTube у
віці 14 років, і був помічений розвідником талантів,
який працював із R&B співаком
Ашером,
після чого він дуже швидко став
світовою сенсацією, так, я чув, що
минулого року він був більш
впливовим  ніж Обама, так,
тому що він номер один у Twitter, у
нього понад 35 мільйонів підписників,
кожні дві секунди з’являється новий. Компанія, яка
аналізує соціальні мережі під назвою Klout, сказала,
що він найвпливовіша людина
у світі через це, але чи
він  насправді більше впливає на них
Обама, ну мм-хм, але все це викриття також
має негативні наслідки для молодих
людей, чи не так, хоча
мільйони обожнювали Джастіна, багато людей,
чи не одне з його відео було
найнелюбовішим, і він мав  велика проблема
з конфіденційністю, за ним скрізь стежать
папараці, і це погано для
всіх,
не байдуже про підлітка добре, давайте звернемося до
зовсім іншого підлітка, Таві Гевінсон
була ще молодшою, коли починала, чи не так
так, їй було всього 11 років, коли
вона завела модний блог під назвою «Новобранець стилю»
, до речі, для британських підлітків
Рукі — це американське слово, яке використовується для позначення
людини, яка в чомусь новачок, о, дякую,
у своєму блозі вона опублікувала фотографії, на яких вона
одягнена в незвичайні комбінації  одяг
і написала про них так, деякі з них
були досить дивними, так, я вважаю, що
багато високої моди все одно дивно,
вона швидко набрала
величезну кількість читачів до трьохсот тисяч
на день, і багато з них були
дорослими, серйозні журнали моди
брали у неї інтерв'ю  і відправив її на
покази мод в Європі та зустрітися з провідними
дизайнерами, такими як Карл Лагерфельд, деякі
люди не вірили, що вона така молода,
як вона була, чи знали, що один журнал
надрукував статтю, в якій говорилося, що письменниця
не вірить, що телебаченню було лише 12 років і що
її засмутило, але вона повернулася назад і
продовжила вести блог, а потім,
подорослішавши, Таві зацікавилася іншими
речами, окрім моди, у 2011 році, коли їй
було 15, вона заснувала журнал для новачків і
о.  nline-журнал для підлітків менш
ніж за тиждень у нього було 1 мільйон читачів
я бачив це дуже вражаюче, хіба
це не всі дівчата-підлітки слухають, ви повинні
переглянути журнал для новачків так, я думаю, це
фантастично, а Леді Гага назвала
майбутнє журналістики  вона наймає близько
50 письменників
і фотографів, дорослих і
підлітків, для новачків, але вона редактор
із загальним контролем, і весь цей час
вона продовжувала вести нормальне життя,
чи не так, вона живе дуже
звичайним життям у маленькому містечку і їде в
школа і так далі, їй ще немає навіть 20,
але я думаю, що написання та редагування дуже
відрізняються від того, щоб бути артисткою
, є великий тиск з боку шанувальників
і преси, хоча деякі актриси, як
Емма Вотсон, здавалося, керують особистим
життям і здобувають нормальну освіту  так,
Еммі Вотсон зараз 20, звісно,
добре, хлопці, я готовий перевірити ваші ві
повіді, давайте подивимося, Пол так Джастін Бібер по
ав публікувати відео на YouTube у в
ці старше 14 років, коли я слухав  так,
у віці 14 років у
Джастіна Бібера більше,
скільки підписників,
можливо, я не слухав тут 10 мільйонів
не більше 35 мільйонів підписників у Twitter
добре
Тедді почав стиль новачка, коли їй було
лише 11, а ти, коли їй було всього
11 років  старий наступний ваш блог незабаром
зібрав величезну
кількість читачів з 300 000, так, ви маєте
рацію, 300 000 читачів на день, тоді один
журнал засмутив Тубі, надрукувавши
статтю про те, що письменник не вірив, що
Таммі було всього 11 12  Приблизно 12 так тітка
Еббі заснувала журнал для новачків Ніна,
дата була 2011, так, це був 2011,
так що це правильно, а потім менше ніж через
тиждень після того, як журнал True Key був запущений,
скільки підписників 1 мільйон давайте
подивимося так, 1 мільйон підписників
про співробітників тітки Еві  скільки письменників, о, я
зроблю це
неправильно  так
ще раз, хлопці, вам може не сподобатися те,
про що співає Джастін Бібер, але вам
може не сподобатися, як важкі одягаються, але
ви не можете сказати, що вони не є
підлітками високих досягнень і не можуть бути
зразком для наслідування, можливо, є нові кумири
з’являються нові зразки для наслідування, як-от
Біллі Айріш або хтось інший, тож настав
ваш час почати щось нове,
ви молоді, ви сповнені ідей,
і ви сміливі, коли все гаразд, тому Пол,
давайте продовжимо говорити про
якості надзвичайно успішних  люди
та хлопці, ми збираємося поговорити про п’ять
якостей, можливо, ви можете придумати більше,
але захочете обговорити п’ять або
нижче, тут насправді ви отримаєте
відповідь на своє запитання, що вам
потрібно знайти і розвивати всередині себе,
щоб бути успішним і  Насправді відповідь
виходить з огляду на тих, хто
створив успішний бізнес, успішну
кар’єру в різних сферах, і ці
риси дуже прості, я вважаю, що
більшість із вас є, але, можливо, вам
потрібно розробити  Попередьте їх трішки, тож Пол
, ви почнете з першого, і
це так, добре, не їздіть на машині,
це Драйв означає мати
рішучість, мотивацію, у вас
є причина робити те, що ви
дійсно хочете зробити, тому ви просто
роби це ти не думай про це ти роби це,
а наступне настає впевненість у
собі впевненість у собі - це дуже приємна риса
характеру, коли ти хочеш бути
незалежним, але в усьому я маю на увазі, що
ти можеш підтримувати своє життя, на який ти можеш взяти
рішення, і ви можете показати свою
відповідальність і бути відповідальним, це
означає, що якщо вам дадуть завдання, то
ви точно виконаєте це завдання, і
ви будете вчасно і дуже добре
виконуватимете,
можливо, важко приймати рішення, але
ви можете прийняти  ці ризики, і ви
приймаєте власні рішення, і ви підтримуєте
своє життя та підтримуєте інших
членів сім’ї, це означає, що
ви впевнені в собі, добре,
наступна риса – це наше терпіння,
щоб бути успішним, вам потрібно терпіння.
терплячі люди, як правило, не дуже
успішні, тому що для досягнення деяких
важливих цілей вам потрібно
робити маленькі кроки, маленькі цілі стають великими
цілями, тому якщо ви не терплячі,
чекайте успіху, якщо ви не готові
страждати від повільного процесу створення, ви  це
не буде успішним, тому терпіння
дуже важливе, так, це як,
коли ви копаєтеся до величезного Демонда
, зупиняєтеся й повертаєтесь назад лише за кілька
сантиметрів, перш ніж потрапити на цей діамант,
тому вам потрібно набратися терпіння.
один - це хороший зв'язок, хоча
вам потрібно бути самовпевненим, але ви
повинні побудувати гарний зв'язок з іншими
людьми, і іноді вам доводиться покладатися на
інших людей, і ви повинні делегувати
свої обов'язки, ви повинні знайти
тих людей, яким ви дійсно можете довіряти
і вони можуть бути справжніми прихильниками для вас,
і, крім того, ви також повинні бути прихильником
для них, тому створюйте свої зв'язки
і думайте про свою мережу друзів і
майбутніх колег, і остання
риса  наше спілкування,
люди – це соціальні істоти, ми не
розвивалися без спілкування. Всі
люблять спілкуватися, у кожного є друзі,
тому це показує вам, наскільки важливе
спілкування для людей, і щоб
бути успішним у будь-якій роботі чи кар’єрі,
неможливо без розмови, потрібно
говорити так  якщо у вас є хороші комунікативні
навички, ви можете краще сформулювати те, чого ви хочете,
і легше досягати своїх цілей,
добре,
давайте підведемо підсумок, тому
спочатку вам потрібно мати бажання, так,
рухатися вперед і бути ентузіазмом,
а другий – це впевненість у
собі, впевненість у собі та незалежність  і
будь людиною, якій можна довіряти терпіння
так,
потім приходить терпіння, вам потрібно бути
терплячим і вам потрібно мати
рішучість, а потім приходять з'єднання,
так, потім приходить з'єднання, створене вашу
мережу за допомогою комунікаційного
спілкування, і це дозволить
вам досягти високих досягнень  підліток і
успішна людина
ну Пол наші єдині зірки та знаменитості,
приклади для наслідування f  або ми, на жаль, їх не повинно бути,
на жаль, ймовірно, є занадто багато
зірок, які є взірцями для наслідування взірцями для наслідування
повинні бути люди, які чогось досягли, а
не просто стали відомими більшість
людей, вони думають про кінець, кінцевий
результат, бути відомим, а не про
процес досягнення цього  для мене
взірцями для наслідування повинні бути люди, які зосереджуються
на процесі та на тому, що вони роблять,
і роблять те, що вони роблять
, хорошим продуктом або успішним, якщо тільки
ви відомі, не
обов’язково означає, що ви є втіленням
ролі  моделі так, це не означає, що
ви досягаєте високих досягнень лише тому, що
ви відомі, і я твердо вірю,
що є певні неоспівані герої, і
насправді хлопці, ці неоспівані герої є
серед ваших родичів, можливо, навіть серед
вашої родини, я думаю, що лікарі  зараз
неоспівані герої, і насправді вони
роблять все можливе, щоб боротися з пандемією
і так далі. Я вважаю, що вчителі
також можуть бути прикладом для наслідування, і я вважаю, що
вчені дуже чесні політики та є.
uk персонажі книги можуть бути прикладами для наслідування
і навіть історія, яку Ольга розповідала
мені сьогодні про свого друга, який врятував
і врятував маленького оленя, чия мама
зникла  ви
можете знайти людину, яка вас дійсно
надихає, і ми попросили вас
зробити проект про його життя або про
її життя, і чому ця людина
важлива для вас насправді, це ваше
домашнє завдання, інше питання полягає в тому,
що ви хотіли б  будь для когось прикладом для наслідування
або ти вже є прикладом для наслідування,
і ти можеш створити проект або
написати твір і поділитися ним з нами та
зі своїми друзями. Я дуже
надихнув цей урок, тому що
підлітки завжди надихають мене своєю
сміливістю  ідеї та їхнє натхнення
Пол, що ти думаєш про нинішніх
викладачів так, коли я викладаю на уроці,
це завжди надихає один із
найкращих один із найкращих позитивних моментів у тому, щоб
бути вчителем, студенти надихають  e ви,
хлопці, це взаємний процес, ви надихаєте
нас, ми намагаємося надихнути вас
добре, це відповідь на урок, який
говорить, мийте руки до наступного разу,
до побачення
[Музика]
ви